this is a production of cornell
university
great thank you andy i hope you can hear
me
um so yeah uh welcome it's uh uh
it's always a privilege to be able to
present
a a seminar i'm going to talk about soil
health carbon and nutrients and try to
kind of bring some of these things
together based on
our recent research so yeah first i want
to sort of acknowledge it's been a while
i am seeing many of you for probably
over a year this is what i looked like
um about a year and a half ago when the
picture was taken by uh by
kirsten kurtz and um so we've all aged a
little bit and this is kind of what i
look like now
uh no that's just a joke this is one of
those apps that makes you
look older so don't worry you can see me
here on the
on the screen i'm still healthy all
right what we'll cover
uh soil health and you know i won't go
into detail because it's something that
we've talked about a lot
um carbon and nutrient flows because
that's really an
important consideration and i'm going to
back that up with some uh
interesting results and then we'll shift
and talk about nitrogen
and why it's important and the
challenges with it and how nitrogen and
soil health
kind of interrelate obviously i'm going
to be talking about computational
approaches through adopt-in
and why that is uh a way to move forward
and how we integrate the knights in soil
health and carbon
management and then uh sort of at andy's
request i'll talk a little bit about
public and private sectors and you know
because of my experience working with
yara international
on my sabbatical last year uh try to
convey some perspectives on that as well
okay i also like to start out with you
know at this sort of very basic level
on my perception on on what makes soils
and you know soils are we kind of start
out with with
particles you know not solid rock with
particles and what
uh soil particles have this ability to
retain water in its force uh between the
particles and that's you know we call it
capillarity
and it's really a very kind of
foundational process
in soils because by being able to hold
water
soils can slowly dissolve minerals
typically with a lower health from some
acidity from the air
and that you know creates weathering
that dissolves minerals
and the soils that also have the ability
to retain those minerals through
various bonding mechanisms and the
secondary processes is then
because there's water and there's
minerals and then there's sort of the
the genetic base for uh organisms
to use that and
and then we bring in basically an
organic component so plants
to some extent uh other organisms as
well
then take that take the carbon and the
nitrogen from the air it doesn't come
from the soil minerals that's what comes
from the air
and it captures that through
photosynthesis it captures
uh solar energy uh and that uh
basically builds up in the soil it
supports other organisms either soil
borne or above ground
um and uh we basically built a storage
reservoir for carbon nutrients and water
that's really what what the soil is and
that
and a healthy soil has plenty of that
um but there is sort of a saturation
point
you know soils can uh hold a certain
amount
of carbon and nutrients and primarily
defined by
things like texture and climate and
vegetation what the original vegetation
was and
drainage et cetera okay but i like to
see
soils as as this storage reservoir that
that supports
you know all these um you know
terrestrial life forms and and of course
also the
the food system but just to you know
give you sort of a sense as you know you
the soil has one percent organic matter
in the soil it contains about 10 000
kilograms per hectare of carbon and
about
maybe one tenth of that in nitrogen so
this is
a reservoir that we then can use for
various purposes
and we've certainly done that because
much of
the land that is in any way productive
you know has been converted for human
uses
and um in some parts of the world a long
time ago in the
in the americas you know relatively
recent
um and so what we did we cleared the
vegetation we
tilled the soil we stimulated the
decomposition of the organic matter and
release of those nutrients with that
some negative
impacts the the physical exposure
uh and the degradation of the structure
uh caused erosion but in general through
agriculture
we slowly kind of uh reduced its
reservoir we
slowly depleted it and and some of the
associated functioning that went with
that was also becoming
a compromise so here's a picture that
was taken by
kirsten um uh uh
from a soil in eastern nebraska
that uh on the left is the virgin
equivalent and on the right is an is a
field that was quite adjacent to to the
uh
to that remnant the virgin remnant and
you know obviously see less organic
matter you see
you know structural degradation and all
that and if you do this of course
you know for a long time period
especially in a system where
a lot of the carbon and nutrient is not
are not very well cycled you end up
sometimes with extreme situations like
we had with the dust ball or what you
maybe see here
a picture from erosion in the in in the
palouse
so that's sort of the the history and we
now recognize that those are
some of those problems and that we can
address that
so this graph here you may have seen it
it's from the
usda economic research service that that
shows the
technological innovations that sort of
helped improve
agricultural productivity um so the
inputs have that's the green line have
been relatively
stable but the outputs have gone up a
lot and have
kind of quadrupled from say 1930 to
2020. and the total factor productivity
kind of went along with that
um and these are you know the
innovations that you know you're sort of
familiar with
um i think that uh in a couple of years
from now soil health will also be on
this i
really truly believe that that the
productivity
of the soil through its health is uh
is in many cases compromised and
addressing that i think
will allow us for some productivity
increases so
i hope to see uh this little box here
soil health practices
on the on the graph in a couple of years
so i already did it for him
just to make it easy so here it is soil
health practices
uh we're gonna have some benefits from
that
so um i just uh just a couple of months
ago
i finished working on a chapter for
the book that janus teas and norm uphoff
are publishing they're working on the
second edition
biological system i forgot the exact
title
but many of you are familiar with the
book it's a great book
but if we think about soil health and
how we assess it how do we
monitor it we can kind of think of the
hierarchy at the highest level we have
sort of ecosystem services uh like food
production
um water availability things like that
so we can assess that by these very
general metrics you know overall food
availability
at the global level or national level or
regional level or whatever
ecosystem services are supported by
functions of the soil
so one of the functions is is is to
support plant growth so we can
assess that by say measuring crop yield
which we now can do very easily
in many cases because we have yield
monitors we can even look at the spatial
distribution of the yield
functions are supported by processes
like mineralization rate or infiltration
um those are difficult to measure
typically an expensive semester
so we often resort to indicators uh
that that are easier to measure
inexpensive
and that will tell us something about
how the processes are working
and therefore how the soil is
functioning and what the ecosystem
services outcomes are
so we've been focusing a lot on uh on
several indicators
um and you know because i wrote this
chapter i sort of did a
little review of what's all out there
and um
so this is a table that shows the
physical
biological and chemical indicators
because soil health really is about the
integration of those
three realms and what sort of are the
the common measurements so on the right
side you have sort of your
typical chemical indicators uh extracted
macro and
micronutrients which are typically an
indication of how well they are
available to plants
very well established technology by now
a lot of good work has been done
uh in the in the 40s to the 60s and
everybody now uses a typical soil test
so that's well established ph also of
course salinity so cydicity
uh where appropriate as well as you know
toxic uh
elements and and other contaminants on
the left side
i think we've seen quite a bit of
convergence around
physical indicators especially aggregate
stability being extremely valuable very
good indicator of
how the soil is performing physically
and then some other ones plant available
water macro porosity and bulk density
the central uh column is the biological
indicators and because
we haven't really done that mark we i
really uh you know the the soil science
community
um oh this is a little bit more of a
frontier still there
there's a lot of new um methodologies
that have been developed
that are being tested and there hasn't
been quite as much convergence yet on
water appropriate indicators and they
range from
you know a basic sort of organic amount
of content or
maybe carbon and nitrogen by combustion
analysis
to simple measurements like respiration
uh
permanganate oxidation of carbon which
we call active carbon
to some of those other ones like the
fatty acid profiling
enzyme profiling methodologies all the
way to molecular genetic profiling
through dna analysis
and so we're still kind of sorting that
out some of our colleagues like
like janice and dan buckley are kind of
working actively in
in this area many around the country as
well now
we uh because we started to work in soil
health
about 20 years ago we sort of were
early developers of soil health
assessment
and developed what we now call the cache
approach comprehensive assessment of
soil health
and you see a sample report here we
focused
uh on four physical for biological and
seven
chemical indicators and they were
primarily selected based on
how they related to soil processes um
whether they were low cost uh easy
sampling and all that
and that has held up since we wrote this
out in 2006 has held up pretty well
so we measure these indicators we
interpret the numbers we score them
we look at an overall score
and we link them to management
guidelines and we've talked about that
before so i don't want to go into
details
but i need to give you a little bit of
background
because of what i'm going to be
presenting next
so one of the things that we were
interested in because we were starting
to
accumulate a pretty good database on uh
on soil health
is that a few years ago um i asked aubry
fine
who was at the time had just finished
her master's degree in our department
and she worked with us for a while
what if she was interested in doing some
data analysis
and so one of the things that we looked
at was you know is there any difference
between
different regions of uh of the country
and we had enough data
for the northeast of course the
mid-atlantic and uh
and the midwest and of course we sort of
expected that the midwestern soils in
general would be of higher
uh health better uh scores you might say
uh in part because there are grassland
soils and and all that
well we were surprised that it was
actually the opposite that it turned out
that for these indicators the uh
midwestern soils
tended to score the lowest so if you for
example look at the organic matter
content
the midwestern soils had a full one
percent
lower organic matter content than the
eastern
uh soils on the average uh a good
stability
quite a bit lower 25 versus you know uh
in the 40s and so this really puzzled us
and but the initial explanation that we
had is like well there's probably
differences in cropping systems
most of the samples in the midwest came
from corn soybean
fields uh while most of them from the
east coast were more
you know maybe had involved livestock or
manure application
some you know maybe organic farms
and things like that so that sort of got
us on a path of looking at cropping
systems
um but you know basically what it does
come down to
to some extent is is the basic mass
balance
of uh carbon and nutrients you know what
goes into the soil
and what is being lost right so you kind
of have if you have
the losses less than the gains then you
kind of build up a good pool of soil
organic matter
if you have the reverse then of course
you kind of deplete the
soil organic matter it's just as
basically as simple as that
um and to put that into some general
numbers um
so if we think of a natural system or
maybe an
integrated crop livestock system maybe
something that maybe more resembles a
farm
maybe 100 200 years ago
there was a lot of cycling of carbon and
nutrients you know either
completely naturally you know leaf
litter or die off of roots and
and and and other biomass
um and uh but maybe in these integrated
systems maybe you lose a little bit of
the carbon nutrients maybe the milk and
the meat got sold or something like that
but you mostly have you know uh the
carbon and nutrient cycled
but we've developed more into
specialized agriculture
where we now have a lot of we might say
cash grain operations where the focus of
the
production system is on producing grains
and then those grains are being
harvested and sold off the farms so that
can be corn soybean sunflower wheat
those kind of crops and in that case 60
to 70 percent of the carbon and
nutrients
is lost it's being taken off the field
and sold off the farm
and so a much lower percentage is being
returned
uh add to that maybe additional losses
from uh
tillets and erosion and now you have a
system
where the carbon and nutrient nutrient
cycling
is is very uh very limited and so in a
cartoonish way i put the little
earthworm here on the left that's a
happy worm because there's a lot of
nutrients and energy available and on
the right it says it's a nervous worm
and and we we often see that reflected
into a lot of the biological indicators
that show less favorable for those kind
of cropping systems
so uh and it basically has to do with um
you know at the larger scale with you
know transferring
carbon and nutrients from areas where we
dominate
with cash grain operations like we do in
the central part of this country
the so-called corn and soybean belt or
maybe the palouse region in
washington and uh and a lot of those
products are then
either they some of them are being used
within the region
for livestock production but some of it
gets shipped to places like
western new york where we have a lot of
farms or the carolinas where there's a
lot of
hog production or dairy farms in
california and idaho
and so these grains are easy to ship
and so we have this transfer this flow
of carbon and nutrients
and we see that at the global level
because many countries
are unable to feed the population
at the current and desired diets they
just simply don't have the land resource
base
think of japan and korea being very
mountainous countries is very little
uh land available um and china of course
with a very large population 1.4 billion
even though it has quite a bit of
agricultural land
uh it still needs to import a lot of uh
grains especially soybeans
uh which is also difficult to grow there
it's difficult to grow in europe as well
and so basically the americas and three
countries
uh u.s brazil the legislation argentina
are the major grain exporters but the
way i'd like you to see this also is you
know we're
we're also exporting carbon and
nutrients the basic ingredients of soil
health
and of course we're exporting water
because it takes water to
produce those crops and that's where we
are that's the global system
uh and uh there's advantages to that and
that i think it
keeps a lot of people alive but there's
also uh
some strain on the on the health of the
soil
and then of course on the other end we
have now a problem with accumulation of
carbon and nutrients in areas
where these grains are being shipped to
and these are primarily
the areas where we have a concentration
of livestock
for some economic reason it's uh it
seems to be better to
be growing raising livestock or
including dairy
in concentrated areas but it does sort
of create some problems
with all these carbon nutrient flows so
not only within the u.s
but many other places around the world
so if you look just at pork production
i think this map says it all a lot of a
lot of it is being produced
in areas where they don't have
sufficient land base and that's why
really why
we're shipping a lot of these grains
around the world
and it benefits the u.s farmers but it
doesn't benefit
the health of the soils and it also
creates
you know increasing problems with issues
like
hypoxia and estuaries and all that
because we're moving all this carbon and
nutrients around
so of course a lot of the nutrients are
being replenished through fertilizer so
whether it's
potassium from saskatchewan or
phosphorus from florida
or idaho places like that or maybe
nitrogen from fossil fuels
but what does not get replenished is the
carbon the the biological component
uh sometimes also not the micronutrient
and so yes there's a there's a a balance
uh although that creates problems too
because we may be running out of
phosphorus fertilizer but we're sort of
you know creating this distribution of
carbon and nutrients that is not really
uh favorable uh in that that we are
becoming very deficient in some areas
and we see excesses
in other areas right so carbon and
nutrient flows affect soil health
so going back to our uh cash uh database
um as part of the new york soil health
initiative uh
joseph um silly who i think most of you
know he's an extension associate working
with the program as a as the coordinator
he um he did an analysis of the
effects of different cropping systems
within new york uh because we had a
pretty good amount of
soil samples to analyze so based on crop
coats we were able to
identify different cropping systems so
grain crops you know
primarily associated with crop coats
corn soybean wheat etc
dairy crops you know corn silage alfalfa
etc
um and the big difference of course
being that with the dairy crops there's
the cycling of carbon and nutrients
because the crops are being fed to the
animals and the
and the nutrients and carbon come out
the back end and go back onto the
field while the grain crops of course
export most of the carbon and nutrients
pastures is like dairy crops but not
disturbed not tilled so
that's a good situation processing
vegetables are a little bit like
grain crops in terms of the carbon and
nutrient flows
but we also looked at mixed vegetables
that
are typically smaller heavily
managed systems that focus on the local
markets
often organic or you know
associated with you know supplying local
restaurants and all that
so they of course use a lot of uh
compost or maybe manure
cover crops etc so they have a lot more
carbon inputs
so i won't go into a lot of details
there's there's a
report that we published also joseph is
going to be giving a seminar on this
and talking about a lot more i don't
want to go too far with this
just i want to show you the organic
matter results
okay that's the only one that i'll show
joseph don't worry about it
um but you can see here that the systems
that
uh have a lot of carbon and nutrient
exports
you know and end up with lower organic
matter contents than the ones where
there's a lot more cycling
um and especially pastures being sort of
the best
situation for obvious reasons so you see
quite a bit of differences but i'd like
you to kind of
look at it more in terms of relative to
what you might say
is a like a minimum amount of carbon
that you might expect on the average in
soils which maybe is about two percent
that's just a you know a general number
it's kind of like
uh comparing people's uh heights you
know adults heights
and you can kind of start at five feet
because most people are above five feet
right so if you look at differences you
know start from five feet and
measure the the difference so if you do
that here you can see that there's quite
a bit of difference
in terms of the the more active
biologically relevant organic matter
what this also shows is quite a bit of
difference in terms of the potential for
improvement so clearly
the annual grain and processing
vegetables have more potential for
improvement also have more potential for
carbon
sequestration and carbon storage and and
joseph will talk about that
so what we've really learned is that
soil health varies
through natural variation like texture
drainage climate vegetation clerked if
you want to use
that term and spatial processes i talked
about that in a previous seminar
how there's a kind of you know carbon
nutrients move from
the hillsides to the valleys and the
deltas basically
but now also we've seen that the
anthropogenic factors are
really important cropping systems and
and the nitrogen the nutrients and
carbon flows with that
and by management practices you know are
we using cover crops are we using
reduced tillage etc so
when we think about approaches to
building soil health i think
most of us are familiar with that we've
we've learned about
cover cropping reduced tillage and all
that and i think you can look at it in
terms of reducing
the losses of carbon and nutrients like
using reduced tillage
increasing the capture of carbon and
nutrients like
better rotations cover crops uh you know
perennialized
rotation certainly and and growing
healthy crops
uh you know high biomass crops
um and maybe the third component that we
maybe need to start looking at is
bringing the carbon and nutrients onto
the farms that are deficient
so we clearly should prioritize some of
the fields that
are clearly deficient so one thing one
way to do that is to
kind of rethink the agricultural systems
at the local regional national even the
global level
so think about you know exporting and
importing carbon and nutrients
reconnecting the animals with the crops
in the soil
um and maybe targeting the soils that
are most most efficient
that's where we're going to have the
most benefits both in terms of
improving soil health as well as carbon
capture
so um i want to segue now to nitrogen
because
you know as you know carbon and nitrogen
are heavily interlinked
a lot of the nitrogen in the soil is in
organic form
and thereby associated with carbon so
we've established that soils vary in the
carbon and nitrogen conditions
through natural and anthropogenic
practices
and that if we are going to be doing
more in terms of improving soil health
and we're going to be using some of
those
soil health enhancing practices we're
also creating a much more
complex carbon and nitrogen environment
okay
so if you just in a in a simple you know
growing
corn for grain and all the nitrogen is
applied uh by fertilizer
there's not that many factors involved
it's it's basically how much organic
matter
you know is there and how much might be
mineralized
but when you bring in these more labile
forms or you change the organic matter
content by
tillage or organic amendments you have a
more complex system
okay so uh now with nitrogen of course
we have a lot of
additional concerns it's from an
agronomic perspective it's expensive
the use of efficiency tends to be low
and there's lots of issues now with
climate change
because it's very sensitive to either
you know excess water or or droughts
and we have these multiple environmental
uh impacts that you know that haven't
gone away
energy needs to produce nice and
fertilizer
uh the nitrous oxide being the largest
uh source of greenhouse uh emissions
from agriculture
and the groundwater and hypoxia issues
in terms of water quality
and the particulate formation from uh
ammonia that causes respiratory problems
which
you know in some cases may have
exacerbated some of the concerns around
the current pandemic now in the past
we've relied very heavily on these
biological processes that i
mentioned to go from non-reactive to
reactive nitrogen of course we know
eighty percent of the air is is uh
non-reactive nitrogen
it's extremely plentiful um but
uh it's the reactive nitrogen that sort
of oddly
you might say has been a very limiting
factor so these biological processes
that you're familiar with
have been the primary source and then
over the past 100 years
we've seen these industrial processes
like hebrew bosch
that have allowed us to uh basically
generate
non-carbonaceous nitrogen okay so
nitrogen without
the organic matter the birkeland aida
process i'm just
highlighting that because the company i
worked with last year yara
was a part of norsk hydro which is the
company that
uh that developed this process and
what's interesting about that is is now
it's less much less efficient than
hebrew bosch but there's an interest in
it because you can
basically generate green uh nitrogen
fertilizer
uh by using uh not having to use fossil
fuels so there's kind of a resurgence in
that
um and then of course we have uh then
all these transformations in the soil
uh from you know either the uh the
synthetic
or the organic sources and they are very
much
uh uh mediated by the conditions in the
soil and the temperature
and the moisture conditions it's a very
uh
space-time dependent dynamic system
basically
and it becomes then more complex the
more organic sources
we have and then the management
aspects or you know it matters whether
you're using no-till or something like
that
so we have a complex situation
so how are we addressing that um the map
here on the right
is the uh it shows the nitrogen
recommendation systems that are
that are used around the state and we
basically have more or less
50 systems because we have 50 states and
we have 50 land-grant universities
and every university has to have their
own system and
i love the land grant university system
but i think this is where it's a problem
um and so you can go from one state to
another and yeah
under the same conditions the the
medicine recommendation can
uh vary quite uh
in quite a ways i mean sometimes 50 to
60 pounds per acre
so um and a lot of that has to do with
sort of
um history and and and the fact that
there are people
uh at each university who are
responsible for those recommendations so
they sort of have an incentive to kind
of keep their own system
and so um that becomes then very
difficult when we talk about tools like
adapt and that are
in a way kind of disruptive you might
say uh in a benign way
and so that has been a real challenge
for us uh
then uh there's also uh sort of that a
lot of the the standards and the
regulations are built around
these state by state uh systems and and
um the nutrient recommendation systems
are somewhat unique within our
discipline we don't see that
with say conservation practices or
tillage systems
where we don't have everything different
from state
to state then the other thing that we
were challenged by is sort of
the skepticism about digital technology
so if you have a very simple
um uh recommendation system uh
and focused on a fertilized uh based
system
that's very easy to understand if you
start to bring in much more complex
technology
people are sort of standing back and say
oh wait a minute you know i don't quite
understand this
but the fact of the matter is and i'm
going to be very candid about that
many of these recommendation systems are
quite outdated they were developed
in maybe the 1970s 60s
and and things have changed so
the approach that we are now looking at
is the so-called 4r
uh process and the industry is also very
much buying into that
4r or 4r plus is the nature conservancy
is promoting that
um that means for our plus
good conservation or soil health
management
so for ours relate to the right source
the right rate the right time and the
right
place and uh this all makes sense and we
can
we we have a pretty good idea of you
know what are good sources
of nitrogen especially in the context of
how it's placed
the timing typically closer to
the crop uptake is better the placement
typically in the soil or you know place
according to the different soil types
but the one that's really difficult is
there is the right rate
uh and uh because how do you determine
the
right rate in this very complex system
okay so what is right here
so in a paper from a couple of years ago
a shy seller who was a post-doc with me
we we basically tried to kind of bring
that together in terms of
you know creating this understanding
it's a dynamic system
but when you change one component of the
system or you change
more than one component of the system
there's this dynamic interaction
and it's not a simple additive process
everything interacts with everything
else
right so the basic resources such as
soil type
soil health like organic matter content
the climate
the management factors you know whether
you do tillage or not whether you use
cover crops what rotation
uh the the various nutrient sources
you know organic you know inorganic uh
placement and timing so the the the
three r's
and then of course that all interacts
with uh
with these dynamic uh weather conditions
so
precip temperature solar radiation and
that really
uh needs to be it's a very dynamic
system where
all these factors have a role and can
influence it and
the interactions the transformations and
the losses so that's where the modeling
approach like we've
you know uh started with adapt and you
know uh
is really uh that's basically designed
to deal with that kind of situation
so next would then be if you have those
you do the modeling
and and you use the data and you have
the results from that
that gives you an estimate of what's in
the soil and what's in the crop
and then you may have some other factors
like yield potential
uh prices risk factors and all that
that then allows you to get to the to
the right rate if everything works well
you may want to bring in some external
information like uh
sensing proximal remote sensing
satellites whatever
or you make make some actual
measurements in the field like you maybe
want to take a tissue test or a soil
test
uh they look they can all be helpful in
terms of
making better predictions but the very
simple predictions that are still now
being promulgated
and sometimes they're extremely simple i
always use the example of the state of
iowa which is the
uh the the largest corn uh state
in the country they have one single
recommendation one one one single one
for all soils for
all years for all conditions um and
um and so clearly that's an
oversimplification
so in terms of adapt end then just a
little bit of history
um you know we developed it here at
cornell and and you know
i had a help of a lot of colleagues uh
jeff marconi and john hudson
even going back to jeff wagonet
then we we had that in the public domain
for a long time
that was very difficult for the reasons
i explained before
the 50 state-based system then we
decided to commercialize it through a
startup company
and uh developed it into a cloud-based
platform and
and allowed it to be commercialized and
then um
this company was acquired by yara
international which is a
global crop nutrition company that's
headquartered in oslo
and it's it has a digital farming unit
that i worked with last year so i'm also
disclosing to you
my relationship with with that company
so basically what does adapt then do it
simulates based on
daily time steps because that's uh how
the weather the climate information
comes in
and also based on soil layers
it simulates the water temperature
carbon and nitrogen dynamics in the soil
as it relates to management weather etc
it simulates simultaneously the growth
of the crop
that's corn currently and we also have a
wheat version
the crop and soil models exchange data
and then from that we estimate uh how
much nitrogen is
needed to supplement the the current
situation and then it develops all kinds
of support information
and graphs okay that's the in a nutshell
that's what it does
here you can see some user interfaces um
it has sort of a gis based component it
uh it has alert options that you can get
through
you know mobile devices it also has
ways for consultants to to have summary
information
for all their fields it provides quite a
bit of supportive information
on the simulations as well as some
graphical
uh outputs okay
so what i really wanted to convey uh
today is that
you're using these kind of approaches
these modeling approaches
also allows you to bring in these sort
of sustainability practices these soil
health practices
because a tool like this the way we
developed
it it has it dynamically simulates
manure editions or compost additions it
has a cover crop module
it accounts for differences in tillage
no-till versus conventional tail or
or or minimal tail it accounts for
compaction
it accounts for differences in yield it
accounts for different rotations
and and that's really a key component if
we want to
go more towards soil health building
practices that often
involve organic carbon and nitrogen we
then need to adjust our
recommendation systems it also includes
some
uh enhanced efficiency products like
stabilizers
you can look at the water status and
irrigation and things like that
and it also provides because it does the
simulations and it's quantitative
it gives you feedback on how much that
you lose through leaching or
gracious losses it allows you to do
scenario evaluations one of the big
advantages of models is that you can
manipulate the environment you can do
what if
and so that can be very instructional
in general we did a lot of uh on-farm
evaluation
and i've presented this before i don't
want to go into it as much but the tool
basically works well i mean if you
after a lot of refinement and tweaking
and calibration
we found that these are the adapt end
rates versus the economic optimum end
rate
and it really follows the one-to-one
line really quite closely
and so we're very proud of that it
basically worked
um and uh and uh even it
was a little bit below the uh the
optimum end rate but that's actually now
being approved
again through some tweaking because
that's what you do with a model you
you collect data and you you improve it
we also found that
compared to grower rates that you can
significantly reduce the environmental
losses about
36 percent of the leaching losses and
39 of the gaseous losses so just by
following a more precise recommendation
you already have significant benefits
for the environment we actually
did a lot of calibration of the tool
based on lysimeter work that we did in
northern new york at the willsboro farm
and in the past couple years we went
back and we did
a comparison of the adapt n
recommendations versus the
conventional corn end calculator which
is a static
calculator and found that um you know we
can still reduce
the uh the leaching losses uh
significantly
um by by using this this approach
basically the same you know estimates
that we had before
sort of in that 35 to 40 range okay
so there there are some clear benefits
so what are sort of the overall
advantages of of this approach
so from a commercial perspective and and
i think you know
what i'm trying to encourage you to do
is here to think a little bit uh
commercially because
ultimately if you want adoption in the
marketplace
you have to cater to the commercial
needs right for one it's highly scalable
technology
uh you know any any uh computer
technology is scalable it doesn't cost
much for the additional one acre
uh because you know the investment is
really in developing
the computer code and and the the
hosting sites and all that
so relatively low marginal cost you know
we could go to with adapter and we could
go to
100 million acres you know in a matter
of a couple of weeks if that
if the demand was there currently we're
about a couple of million acres
um it provides predictive prescriptions
um it allows you to continuously monitor
the
the field sort of uh you know without
having to do field visits
this is a big advantage for a lot of the
consultants that spend a lot of time
taking soil nitrate samples in in late
june um
when it's hot and you know um unpleasant
uh you can enhance it with field
observations if you want to do that
it has these alert options so if you
fall below a certain level then
it gave you an alert integrates well
with the variable rate
uh management approach the precision
agriculture you might say it is a tool
and it integrates like i said many
sustainable management practices
i just wanted to kind of mention this
predictive prescriptions and
and and monitoring so uh this picture
here
on the on the top was from a site where
so so at that time we entered it into an
international contest
uh the the two-lane nitrogen reduction
challenge and
um we were a finalist and
we were competing with four other
technologies
and it was a very wet year and uh the
good thing was this is a field in
louisiana
where we had to demonstrate the the
technology i was able to monitor that
field from
my office in my home uh 1300 miles away
and it was a very wet year and we found
that that some of the nitrogen had been
lost
and that the crop would be running out
of nitrogen but you wouldn't see that
from the
from the uh the corn here because it
looks all perfectly green
it looks fine right but the models can
be predictive
and that's a good thing so we predicted
that it was going to be running out of
nitrogen
in about three weeks and so we decided
to have
a rig come in and provide some
additional liquid nitrogen
um through a high clearance equipment
and then so about a month and a half
later
uh this is a shot of the uh the bio it's
a biomass uh
uh uh satellite image that's an actually
a yara product it's called ad farm
and so uh by the end of june is when the
when the corn was starting to
mature uh visits the south it was
planted very early
and you can clearly pick out the uh the
strips
uh where we had our plots the adapt and
plots
uh compared to the other ones and so uh
one of the reasons why we won that
contest
uh was because people were impressed
that we were able to predict
very well uh what those nitrogen needs
were even though they were
clearly not apparent okay um
okay so um i just wanted to mention sort
of uh
some lessons learned uh yara did a
customer survey last year when i worked
for the company
um and a lot of the users you know
consultant farmers and all that
they appreciate the scientific validity
and and i think that's that's really
something
important to to to point out and and
they like some of the utilities that
have been built in
and a lot of that was really you know as
a result of working with a startup
company that was much more
customer focused than than we were
because we were you know
more uh involved with the science
but data is important if you if you want
to make good predictions you have to
have to have good input data okay
um so next steps maybe is uh uh using
the model with um uh with remote sensing
uh like i said the ad farm product which
by the way you can access for free if
you're interested in
um as um um maybe a good integration i
think that's
sort of the next step so finally i want
to say something about
um you know this co-management of
carbon and nitrogen and and why that is
also important for soil health these
pictures were from a long-term 90s
trial in northeast iowa from iowa state
university
and i you know visited the plots they
weren't my plots but i knew they were
there
i took some pictures and you can see
here the plots that had received zero
nitrogen for
many years i think maybe 16 years and
you see the one
on the right with the high nitrogen rate
and
not only do you see the effect on the
plants but you can also clearly see an
effect on the soil
because there's been not enough carbon
and nitrogen being
cycled so not putting fertilizer on is
not necessarily a good strategy
for soil health either you know
sometimes people think that well the
fertilizer is the problem no it's more
complex and taking out the fertilizer
is not the solution all right so that's
um so and if you want to build
uh uh organic matter in the soil you
need carbon but you also need
need nitrogen right because about 10 or
so
of the organic matter of the uh that's
about
um one tenth of the for for each unit of
carbon
you need uh one tenth of the unit of
nitrogen so you still the nitrogen has
to come from somewhere
right now not just fertilizers but
you know you want to have these
biological processes as well
so more recently there's been an
interest in uh
in in sort of establishing a performance
standard
so we have this problem with all these
different management recommendation
systems including adopt them
right and so which one is the right one
and so working with environmental
defense fund
you know they've been really focusing on
this end balance concept
very easy uh calculation you basically
look at how much nitrogen goes into
a uh cropping system in into a field you
know through fertilizer or manure
or whatever and how much do you take off
right
and um so it makes it very simple
so if you if you look here uh the inputs
and the outputs
right and if you were at the zero end
you know your inputs would be very low
you would still get some yield
but not much um but you are in this
zone here where your nutrient use
efficiency is too low
you basically are minding the soil and
we and we saw that in the picture
if you put too much nitrogen on like you
maybe see with the 240
pounds per acre uh yes you get higher
yields uh but you have that also with
high inputs
and um and your but your your your
efficiency is is overall too low um
so it's not bad for the soil but it's
bad for the environment so this is a
safe operating space for in fertilizer
where you are putting in enough to have
really high productivity but you're not
putting in more than that
right so we did some
research where we did simulations with
shy and uh also involved peter woodbury
in our department
um where we uh didn't end balance
and so the the the safe space is sort of
between the zero and
and sixty uh because beyond 60 you're
starting to see significant
environmental losses
and we looked at the timing and and the
use of nitrification inhibitors in
in the midwest over seven year period
and what you see here mostly is that if
you do fall applications which
is not is poorly timed for uh for a
summer crop you see uh that you're
outside
the optimum range you know you're you're
wasting uh
you're losing too much fertilize if you
use an inhibitor or stabilizer
you do better you improve the
performance and you're closer
to the the green line if you go to all
spring applications
with or without inhibitor you're getting
pretty close
and the inhibitor actually doesn't give
you a lot of benefit but if you go to
split or in season application that's
really when you're in
in the safe zone so we're trying to link
the use of these tools with you know
possible policy initiatives
okay so finally just a couple of minutes
because andy asked me
to address this so my experience over
the past years has been maybe somewhat
unusual
especially certainly in a college of
agriculture um
with uh working with companies uh and
and the private sector and it's been
really enjoyable uh i have to say so i
worked with startup companies like uh
agronomic technology corporation which
is a company that
uh that uh licensed adapt then
we're also doing some work with a
company that's called robot it's a
robotic company
if i have some time i'll show you a
slide and others to a lesser extent
i found these experiences to be very
interesting
they're small companies they're very
dynamic they don't have bureaucracies
they make decisions
you know when they need to i found
a lot of these people to be very
talented
entrepreneurs are a different breed and
and i have a lot of respect for them
um the companies are very focused
they're focused on one or two things
um but they have very limited resources
they're they're often
you know doing things on a shoestring um
because they
have to work off venture capital um
and so it's uh but great experience
so then because atc was acquired by yara
i had a lot of experience working with
them i did my sabbatical you know for at
least part of the year last year didn't
work out so well because of the pandemic
got some experience with working with
danone as well the
it's a french dairy company and walmart
about five six years ago as part of
their sustainability initiative
i i found that very different you know
they have a lot of resources
um they sometimes are highly profitable
companies and they're they're willing to
invest
uh but you also have a lot of players uh
typically that you
that you're working with um the uh you
were working with
mbas or people that you know maybe have
experience in digital technologies but
in a very different area
uh nothing related to agriculture but
they also do have powerful connections
for
yara is because it's a big global
company they partner with ibm
and the weather company on on on weather
data
and uh that's you know a type of access
that you wouldn't have
um but you're also working within a
company that has many other objectives
you know like uh atc was focused on just
adapt and
uh made it very simple okay
um and it's also you know you often sort
of struggle a little bit with you know
working with people with mba degrees who
who don't really understand you know the
complexity of what we're dealing with
they sometimes want a
simple solution and you have to say no
it's really a lot more complex than that
and then i also had some good
interactions with ngos like
edf and the nature conservancy and i
won't take time but
those uh they're they're good people
they often have similar constraints to
what we're dealing with
at universities but i think they also
have a very important role they also
have often very good connections
either with the private sector or
university so they they have a
good bridging function just quickly one
of the show
robot because that's uh you know we have
some active collaboration
it's a company that uh was founded by a
cornell graduate
um and it makes small field uh robots it
has a lot of sensors on it and
um so uh zafar vestas who is a phd
student with me
most of you know him we're working on
this lower canopy sensing to look at
medicine medicine deficiencies
also it has a uh we work with them on
developing a cover crop seeding option
so
because it has a rubber tracks
um it drops cover crops uh seeds
right in front of the tracks then it
runs over them to kind of uh
incorporate and give good seed soil
contact and you really get
pretty good results in terms of cover
crop establishment so that's another
it's kind of an exciting opportunity
okay so uh finally uh summing it up
you know we really need to think in
terms of better integration
of uh carbon nitrogen and soil health
and it really is a win-win-win
opportunity we can get more carbon into
the soil we can improve the health of
the soil we can
make nitrogen use more efficient
and we can improve yields so the
improving organic matter requires
nitrogen uh but eventually reduces
nitrogen needs especially if you can
account for them
with with good recommendation systems
so and i as i mentioned you know there's
a lot of things that we can now
incorporate into these models
that allow us to be more nuanced about
uh knights and recommendations
and finally i wanted to mention just a
two days ago joseph sent me
this it's uh in albany they're talking
about
a uh the drafting some legislation
related to
soil health and um and uh and so
uh resiliency so that's kind of
interesting uh
uh it took a long time for new york to
sort of get excited about soil health
even though we were doing a lot of work
but now
um they really want to go all out and so
it will be very exciting if we can see
some of this legislation uh uh coming
about so
let's keep our fingers crossed uh it's
still in in in draft form but uh
if this happens then that would be great
all right thank you very much i want to
acknowledge uh the individuals that are
listed here that sort of contributed uh
in many ways
and uh also the the funding so with that
uh
andy i'm gonna um throw it back to you
and
open it up for questions thank you so
much harold you've covered a tremendous
amount of ground
uh so we're we're a little bit over but
harold you have time for a couple
questions if there's some from the floor
i certainly do yes
people want to stick around great so uh
open
open floor uh if you'd like to to uh
pose a question please just um meet
yourself and
and go ahead and ask carol
zoom mannequin harold i think it's
complicated
i'll ask you one okay short one it's
curious on the
within the adapt and framework if you
are doing an in-season yield forecast
now
is as part of the recommendations logic
and how you're handling that if you are
um yeah we're actually not doing an
in-season yield forecast
um and it's something that we'll
probably
uh will be working on we've we
felt that and you know based on
interactions with
consultants and and farmers that they
typically have a much better idea of
that
themselves because they they they know
their yield records of course they know
the yield records that's their bottom
line right
and so and and they have some sense of
whether there needs to be some
adjustment based on on whether
so we leave the uh the the yield
estimate
uh the yield goal actually to the user
and we're not
we're not estimating it we could uh the
model does allow for it and
it does a pretty good job but
i think it actually doesn't do as good
of a job as the
farmer or the consultant themselves
based on the historical records that
they have yeah interesting thanks for
that harold
other questions from the floor
[Music]
i have a question
um hi harold so has
has adapted and been used in other
countries yet and
if not art do you have any plans
for that um yeah no that's that's a good
question in fact
um that's what i spent a significant
part of last year on was uh
was enabling the tool for other uh
geographies so um that included brazil
uh argentina uh europe and south africa
so we we basically got the databases the
soil databases and climate databases all
uh for those geographies
um you know it's interesting when you
work within a company
um yara actually is
is not that well known within the u.s
they focus more on specialty crops um
and they like for example they're they
don't sell a lot of fertilizer
in uh in places like iowa uh in in the
corn belt
uh um so but in brazil they
uh they control about 60 of the market
uh so they they're
they're a dominant player in brazil to
lesser extent
argentina uh and of course in europe
they're very big because they are
a norwegian based in norway based
company
um so we basically you know got it ready
for uh for those new geographies um but
there there's a lot involved you know
you can't just kind of say oh here's the
tool it's available
you need to have a a billing
infrastructure you need to have
partners to work with um and all of that
so and probably in brazil
it will probably be rolled out through
their own consultant network
uh while in the u.s we work with
partners uh you know yara doesn't really
have any
doesn't do any consulting uh or
fertilizer sales
you know and where adopt then is being
used so in the us and canada
we're working through other companies
like uh
mfa the missouri fertilizer association
they're i think
maybe about the fifth largest fertilizer
dealer um in
in the us and and they use a dot then uh
and there's a lot of consultants
um even some of the competitors like
nutrient
is a competitor to yara they actually
you know use adapt and
every geography is is different in terms
of
of of how it can be used but we did the
sort of the the technical work the
scientific work
to enable it uh and and so it is
functional in in
and we've tested it in those other uh
areas but that doesn't mean that
that's been rolled out yet and
commercialized it just takes a lot more
than that
and it also kind of it it sort of brings
like i was saying
you know the the the the company has a
lot of priorities um
and adopting is just one of those you
know uh so
it it's sometimes you just have to wait
till other things
um have been resolved yeah
what scale do you see it being used at
like is it mostly for
larger farms or could it have what does
it cost for farmers could it eventually
be scaled down to smaller scale
farms or um yeah so so
this is something that the the startup
company really tried to address
so initially when when it was ours when
it was still within cornell before the
licensing
um you know was basically open to
anybody um
when the startup company commercialized
it um
they did the same but they in terms of
the there is it's available to
to anyone but in terms of their
marketing they
focus more on on aggregators so you know
other fertilizer companies or or
consultants
uh primarily because the cost of dealing
with
many small uh farms is is just
it was exorbitant too much for a startup
company uh now yara may
maybe you know will have a different
philosophy um
but but obviously so and in terms of the
the pricing when you go to a large
client
you know and and say a client signs up
for
let's say a half a million acres you
know you can
provide a much better better pricing for
that than you do for
somebody who has you know a hundred
acres um
so obviously because he with with
computational technologies
the economies of scale are are are
incredible
right i mean it it it uh unless you know
sort of hardware type companies where it
costs a lot to
to produce the hardware with
computational technologies
the more acres the more you can spread
the cost right so so that's why
companies have an incentive to say you
know if you want to sign up for half a
million acres we can give you a really
good deal
that's kind of how that works i see
so and and i agree i mean there's a
downside to that in terms of
you know uh smaller farmers and that you
know maybe needs to be addressed at some
point in time um
the start the startup companies are in
survival mode i mean it's just i mean
day to day i remember you know one day
you think like oh this is all going
great and
and all that and then and then the next
week you
you know you have something you're like
oh we're going to be out of business you
know and you know by next month
so it's a real roller coaster and
working with a larger company like yeah
at least you have that stability yeah
and and i should add i was not really
involved in the business and for the
startup company we really
we just did the science but of course i
talked to them about it
interesting thank you thanks for the
question kira
we should probably close in in a minute
is there any other burning question for
harold before we uh give him our thanks
i have a very uh actually easy question
because it goes back
to the very beginning of your seminar
harold but it still
uh puzzles me because you're showing the
organic matter content in the midwest
versus
in new york in the northeast and your
point was that
in the grain crop production they're
removing all that grain
carbon on the other hand we know that in
something like corn
uh 50 of the biomass
above ground is uh in the stover the
leaves in stem
and so that would be returned back to
the land right
whereas here in new york we're
harvesting 50
of our corn as silage and we remove
a large fraction of the above-ground
biomass
and then i'm also thinking about those
forages
alfalfa grass and we cut them three
times a year and remove all of the
forage
so uh can you help me understand what's
going on there
yeah i i the timid it's a lot of this
is is the cycling so you're you're right
a
you know uh depending on you know
whether you look at the carbon or the
nutrients like
like you say when you harvest corn it's
a little bit it's more
more like 55 or something like that of
the of the biomass right gets gets
harvested
and um but the nutrients of course in
the
in the grain um you know are higher than
in the stover right other than potassium
um and and so so you're
removing those and they're just gone
right i mean you know like in a catch
grain operation they're just
you know uh but in a in a livestock base
let's say a dairy system
you're right you're harvesting all the
um
the entire plant you know other than the
roots um
but you are returning most of that
through manure you know it
it it comes back at least a significant
part of it and
um and that you know from what we can
see in the data that does seem to matter
now when you go to a perennial system
right i mean the other advantage of
course that that a dairy system has a
typical dairy farm in new york will
have corn silas and then they'll grow a
perennial you know alfalfa
or some alfalfa grass mixture or
whatever and so
so they have you know at least part of
the rotation is
is a perennial crop so that has benefits
um
and yes you harvest most of that but you
know apparently
going then having someone that returns
through manure
sort of gives you that that net benefit
um
i mean you know i would love to talk
some more with you about that tim
because
you know you are much more of an expert
in in that part
we're just kind of we have the data now
to
to do the the analytics and to say
hey you know these you know um we are
seeing these kind of patterns
yeah so so next week yeah it it really
is
and and um uh yeah so next week uh
joseph i think it's next week joseph
is going to be doing the seminar and so
he'll go a little bit more in
into depth on that um but i think it's
it's not really
very well recognized that these carbon
and nitrogen flows
um are are so significant you know that
it matters
and it was really that that early study
that aubry find it that we were we were
just puzzled like wired and midwestern
soils
i mean one percent organic matter
different that's a lot that's that's
that's huge you know um so yeah it's
interesting
but let's let's talk about that sometime
and uh i'd like to
get more of your insights on into that
yeah that'd be great thanks very much
very good excellent seminar thank you
tim
and thanks harold really really great
talk and
deeply appreciated and on behalf of
everyone thanks thanks a lot for giving
it
and thanks everyone for attending but
we'll end here
thanks again harold
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu